okay there is a Republican state
representative in Minnesota named Duane
quam and he seems like a really angry
guy he's running against Jamie mahlberg
who's female and Jamie mahlberg is
giving him a run for his money
qualm has been the incumbent and he's
been in for four terms he's the
Republican Jamie mahlberg as the
Democrat they had a debate where they
had to share a microphone which sounds
crazy it's not ideal but in local races
these sorts of things can happen at
debates where even though you've got two
candidates there's just one microphone
available and you've got to pass it back
and forth
Jamie qualms got a I'm sorry not not
Jamie qualms Duane qualms I combined
their names Duane qualm got a turn
answering a question
then it was Jamie mal Burke's turn to
respond and as she finishes speaking
qualm rips the microphone from her hand
and she sort of jumps her startles and
it's all on video let's take a look and
you can hear the crowd sort of gasp
taken aback when he grabs the mic out of
her hand
that formula increases over time with
inflation thank you thank you
the problem we've got in education is we
are funding failure so he this is this
very angry rebuttal which also was just
terrible policy I mean his education
policy is also terrible but maybe we'll
get to that and then when he's done with
this rebuttal he goes to hand the mic
back to Jamie mahlberg and she doesn't
immediately take it she just sort of
seems to want nothing to do with this
guy and he tosses the mic at her and if
you're listening to what we're about to
play and not watching it like if you're
listening on the radio or on the audio
podcast you're gonna hear a crashing
sound and that's him throwing a live
microphone onto the table in front of
Jamie mahlberg take a look and the
formula builds in funding failure what a
disgusting human being and I was
watching this I don't know how many
people have seen the film office space
the cult-classic office space
this guy's physical appearance reminds
and his demeanor reminds me of a cross
between Milton from office space and Tom
from office space we have a side by side
by side but I that I made yesterday and
you'll see Duane qualm on the left
Milton from office space in the middle
and Tom from office space on the right
it's unfortunate it's an unfortunate
thing yeah this is the new civility
anyway he later apologized and said he
he ripped the Mike out of her hand and
then threw it back at her because he was
nervous and that's kind of funny because
if Duane qualm was running against
another big male like him would
nervousness also lead to him snatching
the mic from his opponent and then
throwing it back at them or is that
something that nervousness causes only
when you're sitting next to a woman like
Jamie I'm Albert I'm just asking Pat oh
yes I get nervous I start attacking
people borderline and get triggered in
this way maybe this is smart in some way
like maybe in the era of Trump this is
what Republican voters in Minnesota want
to see I mean I guess it's possible
although I don't know that much about
this this particular district and then
mota to kind of bring it back full
circle his rebuttal also was a rebuttal
of terrible actual ideas about education
that he espouses like his ideas as bad
as snatching the microphone from his
opponent and then throwing it back at
her his ideas about education are maybe
even more atrocious and disgusting yeah
he sounded so excited so ready to talk
about education policy and then when you
listen to his answer it's devoid of any
meaning it's horrible
would you be shocked at if I told you
that no one respects women more than
this guy like would that would that be
believable or would you question think
I've heard that somewhere before he
respects women second most behind
someone else I'm thinking of he has
binders full of women who want nothing
nothing to do with him whatsoever anyway
if you're a voter in this district
you can vote this guy out in November I
encourage you to do that and I also
encourage you to follow the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
follow me on instagram at david pakman
part two of my inner
with Nathan J Robinson is coming up next
importantly about the intellectual dark
web a subject which Nathan J Robinson is
written about a lot do we call him
Nathan J Robinson because there are
other Nathan Robinson's that are
prominent oh yeah former basketball
player not the NBA point guard they were
about to have on for the interviews I
don't think there's another Nathan
Robinson as well I like that Nathan J
Robinson just to make it super clear
that's like remember uh that lawyer
Howard case Stern who would go because
he didn't want to be confused with
Howard Stern the radio host so he would
go by Howard case there and even though
like he's Howard Stern just like the
other Howard Stern it almost makes you
want to have a middle initial right just
in case there's any confusion between
you and another deokman the other David
Pakman has a middle name so I'm just
David Pakman the other David Pakman is
David B Pakman so you can like if
somebody says David B Pakman it's the
venture capitalists that actually works
out for you pretty well oh I wasn't get
to keep your full name and the Wikipedia
page for David Pakman is mine and you
have to go to David B Pakman to find his
Wikipedia page which is great right I
mean that works out great for me this
almost makes me want to snatch the
microwave from you please do okay please
vote that's I feel like that's my Jeb
Bush please clap please vote in November
because we've got to get this guy out
quick break Nathan J Robinson and then a
lot of other great stuff going on today
one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
which is an incredible online learning
community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video we'll get to
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can
keep getting access to the entire site
for less than 10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up